here's the thing about you and I'm gonna
say something real about you and I'm
gonna say something that you're not
gonna like and it might cause a fight
but I'm gonna say it anyway because I
lost your room okay isn't about any
other [ __ ] you are missing right
hundreds of thousands of dollars by not
doing stand-up you it is an ability okay
it is an ability that you have I've seen
you go up alive you open for me at our
vine remember that one time as a
character David Greco opened for you I
saw I understand that but if Will Sasso
did it yeah you could make so much money
I've told you I don't like stand up for
me
Rosenbaum does it who Michael Rosenbaum
who's that Lex Luthor odd the Smallville
you don't know Michael oh yeah he's a
friend of yours yeah yeah I know who he
is no the allergy should note is you
donating those two should know each
other yeah but you two together with
Rose Michael Rosen bottoms up I thought
you were talking I don't know who you're
talking about some but yeah I know who
that ma it's a [ __ ] it's a chunk of
money that you're missing it's sort of I
know but you don't have to do it that's
fine you never no no no you know why
you're not gonna do it because you're
[ __ ] weak yeah you're ugly you live
in fear you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] do it now
so I'll tell you what I see some bodies
what camera just look at the mirrors I
have it a camera yeah he's doing it to
the camera that's the real Tiger belly
if there's a like a [ __ ] show he's
doing to a hole in the wall like Andy
Kaufman is a ten year old he's like
looking around like there's no audience
full of people here oh he's [ __ ]
hallucinating what's happening it's so
happy with himself
and he's looking he's getting it from
the audience in there here's the thing I
have great respect for stand up I love
stand up I've always you know we had all
the albums when I was growing up I had
an older brother and sisters so my
tastes were sort of you know
you know sort of helped along by them
you know we had the Karlin and all the
[ __ ] and Gilda live that was a good one
great with that on on 8-track and Steve
Martin of course so anyway so here's my
thing I don't you know me I don't really
like to go up in front of people and
talk and give my opinion it's not
interesting to me I think it's I think
it's I think that's oversaturated I
think that your profession as a comedian
is under siege by [ __ ] with
inflated egos who think just holding a
microphone and flapping their [ __ ]
gums into it is something and it's not
and I feel like artistically I want to
and I strive to even though you know we
all try to make things and they don't
always work out or whatever but I'm
always working on something that no
one's ever gonna see and it's been that
way for a long time I don't know that
just getting up in front of people and
going you know I don't know I don't want
to I'm not trying to [ __ ] on stand up at
all I love stand up I love funny stand i
watch a lot of who's the guy I watch
that guy Dave Chappelle yeah and I also
watched the the black guy Chappelle yeah
again yeah I saw that stop the [ __ ]
pal it's not the same guy I know two
different guys oh yeah yeah so I've seen
his I've seen their their Netflix gave
to Bell everyone although Chappelle
would that be funny if Dave Chappelle
had liked it another Chappelle like
should put like Gallagher - yeah cool
okay so anyway but yeah so thank you for
the encouraging words I wasn't and I'm
not going to say I wasn't be encouraging
I know you're just being real that's
Bobby being real Bobby being Bob when
kalila doesn't want to do this anymore
that's gonna be the name of your podcast
Bobby being Bob and you're not gonna go
for jokes just gonna be seriously [ __ ]
and you're gonna have a bunch of like
you know dr. Drew like yes seriously but
no I I would love to do you know I was
having this cut well okay I've had this
conversation before with other people
who I respect medically like yourself
who have taken the time to say do
thank you okay and who have said Oh will
you should be doing some more live [ __ ]
I totally want to I just don't know what
that is okay because I don't want to
bother him all right don't shut me down
and go you don't have to do it you don't
have to do it cuz that's you being
fearful you don't want to hear the end
of what I'm saying oh [ __ ] this unless
this guy wants to get confrontational
yeah you wanna get confrontational you
want to give a [ __ ] you want real
I'll pay myself like a [ __ ] worker
and swim in the shark and pasta while
going mystique I'm not afraid
I'll go misty misty a jellyfish go
inside the ocean home gonna get so trip
anyway yeah I'll do I want to do more
live [ __ ] I'm honestly I have been very
fortunate enough to be busy and out of
10 or college shooting a lot yeah yeah
yeah so and I'm what are you working on
now that I thought that people couldn't
watch I'm the new Batman yeah yeah know
what I got I got a couple films coming
out what are they well the the burning
woman there's one there's a oh I'm in
Super Troopers - oh yeah yeah that's
coming out myself Tyler Labine and Hayes
MacArthur you know Hayes a lot of Tyler
oh you guys work together me Tyler and
hey love those guys yeah you too Hayes
Hayes MacArthur I love the three of us
are our evil Mounties we're the bad guys
oh that's [ __ ] amazing and and Rob
Lowe is the mayor of a fictitious
Canadian town Wow look with Rob yeah
yeah we nice very nice guy handsome huh
yes handsomest [ __ ] yeah yeah 64 years
old I mean [ __ ] and believe that we must
sleep in a hyperbaric chamber
yeah and yes I got a couple of you know
filmy films coming out we're doing
another season of the show I did last
year called Loudermilk which is Ron
Livingston and myself oh that was good
yeah yeah and I'm doing this and that
and that this and I'm ended up on things
I'm going off to shoot a film and
about a month here they were shooting in
Georgia and and yeah but I would love to
do forget it I love stop it that's what
get it done forget it gets me oh [ __ ]
what do we have time why me undies whoo
hey I'm gonna be in Branson whom the way
we end our show is your [ __ ] show yet
captain of this ship
oh yeah yeah okay I love you so much I
love you too I'm a lightweight fire it's
really I'm with my little sticker whale
pufferfish Congress [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
we're not ready
[Music]